je suis à la tête d'un groupe
parlementaire excusez-moi du peu où il y
a des anciens socialistes des
sociaux-démocrates jusqu'aux UDA en
passant par des Outre-mer on nous dit
vous êtes un groupe hétéroclite mais
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette histoire
on est un groupe qui sait dialoguer
discuter on a la clé de la réussite la
clé de la réussite c'est le dialogue
entre nous pourquoi est-ce que nous
faisons entre nous nous pourrions pas le
faire
présent
ce qui est important c'est pas un
président de la République avec une
cervelle puissance 10 c'est un président
de la République avec des grandes
oreilles pour écouter c'est pas la
taille du cerveau qui compte c'est la
taille des oreilles alors ma cancer de
public c'est na nous a rejoint sur ce
plateau bonsoir tam-train nuit bonsoir
et vous aviez donc une question sur la
proposition de loi du groupe liotte sur
les retraites à Bertrand pencher et oui
tous les yeux sont focalisés bien sûr
sur le 8 juin date à laquelle votre
proposition de loi doit être examinée
d'ailleurs est-ce que vous avez un doute
sur le fait qu'elle le soit bien le 8
juin
toujours des doutes ce qui est important
c'est que les parlementaires qui sont
contre cette loi se mobilise après
chacun agira en responsabilité
il y a une manifestation importante le
si le 6 juin
mais on ne sait jamais je rappelle quand
même que notre mot de la motion de
censure a failli passer on voit prêt on
sait pas ce résultat là à vrai dire bon
ça veut dire que il manque encore 9
comme on ne voit pour pour changer la
donne en matière de retraite bon la
notion de censure les abstentionnistes
se prononcent pas je pense que certains
vont être gêné que la majorité soit en
train de d'agir justement pour faire en
sorte que votre texte ne soit pas
débattu vous avez
signé un courrier aujourd'hui vous
interpellez sur vos inquiétudes sur le
fait que certains manœuvres veulent
parler de 10 recevabilité financières
autour de votre texte oui parce que si
pour ne pas passer un texte de loi on
s'en prend à nos fondements
démocratiques c'est-à-dire un parlement
qui est en incapacité de légiférer je
peux vous dire qu'on allume le bâton de
dynamite et je pense que ça sera encore
pire de ne pas voter que pour le
gouvernement et la majorité relative se
faire renvoyer un texte sous la majorité
des paramètres sont contre
en jeu il y a une verte si on ne va pas
jusqu'au jusqu'à l'examen du texte c'est
un bâton de dynamique mais ça serait
dramatique pour la démocratie vous
rendez compte les recevabilité elle peut
pas être soulevée dans le cas de cette
réforme des retraites quand le président
dit ça coûte 15 milliards
financièrement il y a jamais eu aucune
proposition de loi par des propositions
de loi des projets de l'eau vide des
professions de loi venant des
parlementaires on leur a jamais demandé
de faire accompagner tout ça par des
recettes par des recettes équivalentes 1
ça c'est jamais fait dans notre histoire
donc est-ce qu'on veut changer
est-ce qu'on veut changer est-ce qu'on
veut changer les règles en cours de
route c'est quand même très grave on
n'est pas dans un une démocratie
bananière quoi bananière démocratie
ils invoquaient l'article 40 sur votre
proposition de loi évidemment on va pas
marcher en permanence et bricoler
briques fabricoler bricoler notre
commande notre fonctionnement donc moi
ça me paraît ça me paraît invraisem que
ce seul cas est deuxièmement
deuxièmement qu'est-ce qu'on dit à
travers cette proposition de loi nous
prenons nos responsabilités 1 on revient
sur cette augmentation de l'âge légal de
la départ à la retraite parce que c'est
injuste je suis allé faire mes courses
chez Auchan la semaine dernière la
caissière me dit écoutez 67 ans ils sont
fous je vais je vais manger et elle
partira peut-être plus tôt aussi la
caissière peut-être commencer plutôt et
elle va faire peut-être plus tôt la cave
tu vois ce n'est pas je vais ensuite le
lendemain acheter des plats préparés
c'est c'est mon boucher qui me dit je
dois partir en septembre je sais pas
quand je vais partir et je discute avec
la responsable de la Carsat qui me dit
ça fait 20 ans que je travaille à la
Carsat la caisse de retraite j'ai jamais
vu une réforme aussi précipitée
on en revient à l'Assemblée nationale
pour l'instant le texte a été déclaré
recevable par le Bureau de l'Assemblée
qu'est-ce qui peut se passer qu'est-ce
que vous craignez qu'il se passe au
niveau de la de la majorité pour qu'ils
puissent essayer de déclarer le texte
qui recevable
on peut tout imaginer avec qui vous avez
il nous avait promis juré crachait
parole de scout qu'on allait pas avoir
la valise 49-3 ils ont tué le 49-3
bonheur
des tas d'amendements il peut y avoir de
l'obstruction parlementaire de la
parlotte comment de la parlotte à tous
les lignée de la parlotte à tous les
niveaux donc je pense vraiment que
il est vraiment indispensable qui est
pas d'obstruction parlementaire parce
que je pense que le remède serait pire
que le mal
alors je voudrais vous faire réagir à ce
qu'a dit la première ministre la semaine
dernière elle a dit c'est assez
irresponsable de leur part elle part
elle parle de vous de laisser croire que
leur démarche permettra de revenir sur
la réforme des retraites cette
proposition de loi est une façon
d'attirer la lumière en disant pas la
vérité aux Français qu'est-ce que vous
lui répondez et est-ce que vous mentez
aux Français en leur laissant croire que
votre texte pourrait réellement abroger
la réforme des retraites moi je pense
que le gouvernement le président de la
République et la majorité relative ils
sont dans une peur panique et qu'ils
utilisent tous les arguments pour
effrayer les uns et les autres et nous
décrédibiliser est-ce qu'il est
irresponsable que le Parlement se
prononce on est élu au suffrage
universel direct si les représentants du
peuple ne peuvent pas se prononcer dans
quel pays dans quelle démocratie
sommes-nous vous êtes aussi dans un coup
de politique dans un coup médiatique
avec cette proposition de loi mais
pourquoi un coût médiatique un coup
politique si nous nous prenons si une
majorité de députés se prononce contre
ce système de réforme des retraites tel
qu'il a le cheminement démocratique de
la réforme des retraites déjà eu lieu
Bertrand pencher il est terminé ce
cheminement démocratique
est-ce qu'un moment on a discuté de cet
article 7 devenu article 10 de la con de
sur l'augmentation de l'âge légal de
départ
c'est quand même c'est quand même fort
de café que les députés se que les
députés se fanent se prononcent pas et
moi je pense que si les députés se
prononcent ça sera un séisme politique
et je pense que ça aidera d'ailleurs le
président Macron à sortir de cette crise
sociale et politique voyez qui peut plus
sortir sans être camouflé avec vous
voulez l'aider en fait à sortir de la
crise démocratique
gouverner le pays ces quatre prochaines
années intelligemment en se disant que
je me suis trompé bah il y a pas on peut
aussi reconnaître des erreurs je me suis
trompé on va pas passer en force on va
l'aider à trouver des solutions et que
vous allez voir que pendant quatre ans
on va bien travailler pour notre pays
alors au fond est-ce que vous pensez
qu'elle peut être votée cette
proposition de loi oui oui c'est-à-dire
que tous vos alliés
qui vous pensez que vous ferez le plein
de voix à gauche de l'extrême droite
jusqu'à
les filles je pense que des parents
les
parlementaires républicains il y en
avait il y en a 19 qui ont voté la
motion de censure quand même un acte
fort j'imagine pas que les
parlementaires qui ont voté l'émotion de
censure ne viennent par voter cette
cette
propositions
qui sont pas déplacés qui m'ont dit bah
si on avait su on l'aurait fait bon on
me dit qu'il y aurait à peu près 25
parlementaires LR contre cette réforme
il y en a beaucoup qui vont s'abstenir
bon vous rajoutez tout ça donc je pense
ça va passer je pense que c'est pas
certain mais ça va passer mais je pense
que vraiment d'abord si nous votons ça
sera la revanche au moins de la
démocratie on pourra regarder nos
électeurs les yeux dans les yeux en leur
disant vous avez vous avez désigné à
l'Assemblée nationale on a tout fait
pour faire passer ce texte on en est
dans une démocratie il faut que la
démocratie puisse s'exercer
[Musique]